if you can wait 90 days for the results
of the action you've taken you can win
if you can wait a year you can win big
if you can wait a decade you can be the
best if you can wait a lifetime you can
change the world most people convince
themselves that they're smarter than
they are by changing courses rather than
committing to the obvious thing for an
unreasonable amount of time if you can
commit to those actions for an extended
period the longer you extend the time
Horizon around the bigger the
undertaking you can have and the more
impact you can ultimately make so many
people are living paycheck to paycheck
that they can't see beyond the corner
they can't think long term and if you
can just say hey I want to give to a
community for a year you'll be set for
life if you give to a community for a
decade you'll make more money than most
people make in a lifetime if you can
give to the world for the rest of your
life you can actually change it